what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and in this video i
will reveal the full terrifying story of
daki and yutaro i will explain how and
why they became demons why they both
shared the title of upper moon 6 despite
being two different people and why muzon
refers to them as his special demons
ducky and gyutero are among the best
villains in a series that is full of
amazing villains with compelling
backstories so let's break it all down
right now if you guys enjoy our demonstr
content and you want us to keep it going
just leave a quick like and comment it
only takes a second but it helps a lot
with the youtube algorithm and if you're
new to anime out pro or maybe you watch
our videos but you just haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications before we
get into it a quick thank you to nordvpn
for sponsoring this video if you guys
know me you know that one of my biggest
pet peeves is paying full price for a
streaming service only to find out that
a bunch of the content on that service
is not available in my country i'm in
canada so i often ran into these issues
with us-based streaming platforms and it
is completely unfair if i'm paying full
price like everyone else then i should
get full access to all the content like
everyone else thankfully nordvpn allows
me to easily do exactly that whether i'm
at home or traveling i just open the map
click on a location and i'm connected in
seconds i never have to worry that i'll
miss out on watching awesome anime
because i don't have access to them in
my country it's super easy it's the
fastest vpn out there according to
multiple speed tests and it's available
on every major platform including
windows android android tv ios mac os
and linux try it out for yourself go to
nordvpn.com anime outpro vpn to get a
two-year plan plus one additional month
with a huge discount it's risk-free
because nord even offers a 30-day
money-back guarantee just click that top
link in the description or go to
nordvpn.com
animeopro or vpn right now finally this
video will contain manga spoilers about
daki and yutaro in particular so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned daki and yuta are introduced in
the red light district arc of
demonstrator and initially we are led to
believe that upper moon 6 is just docky
herself ducky is a vicious demon who has
been alive for over 100 years and who
has been playing the part of an odan
within the red light district for many
generations daki has been thriving
within the unique environment of the red
light district because she is able to
abduct and devour humans without raising
a lot of suspicion this is because if
she devours another woman from the
district everyone just assumes that the
woman ran off with a man and no one asks
too many questions that said because
docky has been living in this same area
for generations she has had to cover her
tracks once in a while one of the first
things we see doki do is kill an elderly
woman who realized that daki was the
same evil oda that her grandmother had
told her about as a child since that
odan should have died generations ago
the old woman knows that something is
off about ducky and sodaki disposes of
her early on in the red light district
arc we see muzon coming to pay a
personal visit to daki he notices that
she has gotten much stronger because she
has been devouring so many humans lately
we also learned that she has apparently
killed seven strong hashira in the past
and muzon says that he has high hopes
for her he even calls her a special
demon but more on that later we
eventually learned that ducky is not
what she appears to be well that goes
without saying because she appears to be
an oiran but she is actually a demon
however even her demon form and her
position as upper moon 6 are not as they
appear after tengen manages to corner
and behead ducky the fight appears to be
all but over but instead of dying after
being beheaded daki calls out for her
older brother and then a strange
emaciated looking creature emerges from
ducky's back the creature's name is
gyutero he is ducky's older brother and
it is clear right away that he is far
stronger than ducky herself yutero is a
misshapen creature whose body is full of
scars stains and other marks as soon as
he appears we get a hint that his human
life has been extremely tough although
he barely even remembers his human life
anymore his name comes from the word giu
which is used by barkers to entice
people to come into the red light
district this hints at the fact that he
grew up around the district and that his
mother may have been one of the um
ladies of the night duterte claims that
he has killed 15 hashira over the course
of his long lifespan and daki claims to
have killed an additional seven as we've
heard before it is emphasized that both
daki and yutaro suffered in their past
and the way that they deal with this
injustice is by inflicting suffering
upon others as revenge for how they
themselves were treated and they also
want to make sure that no one ever gets
a chance to put them into a position
like that again the two of them learned
how the world really works the hard way
and so they show no mercy to anyone
whenever they cause harm to someone who
was blessed in life and who had an
easier life than them they see it as
collecting on the debt that is owed to
them by the rest of the world they want
to cause misery equal to the unhappiness
that they themselves experienced after
gyotaro appears we learned that he and
daki are intrinsically connected and
that they depend on each other taki
becomes stronger once gyotaro awakens
and yutero has the ability to see
through ducky's eyes which allows him to
get a better view of the battlefield
utero also has the ability to control
daki which underscores the fact that
gyutaro is the strongest sibling and the
main component of the upper moon 6 team
however gyutero isn't always controlling
daki and she does have her own free will
we then finally learned the dark and
tragic backstory of daki and gyotaro and
how they became demons in the first
place the two of them grew up in the
lowest caste of the entertainment
district their mother died of a disease
when they were both young and ducky's
real name ume is apparently a reference
to this disease now the word ume itself
means plum but as is often the case with
japanese depending on how the word is
spelled it can also be a reference to
syphilis which is an std in the modern
world this disease is nowhere near as
dangerous as it once was thanks to the
invention of penicillin but back when
ducky's mother would have contracted it
which i assume is around the year 1800
it would have been extremely deadly and
so ducky and yutaro grew up in the
lowest cast of the entertainment
district and kids in this situation are
considered to be just a nuisance and
they were completely unwanted by
everyone keeping kids like this alive is
nothing but an unwanted expense to the
other inhabitants of the district so
they were treated more like stray
animals than like human beings even
while their own mother was still alive
she actively mistreated them and acted
like she didn't want them so gyutero had
to step in and take the responsibility
of protecting his little sister from a
very young age on top of that gyutera
was born with a weak body and physical
features that were considered very ugly
as a result he was relentlessly bullied
and abused as a child since he was dirty
smelly flea and lice ridden and labeled
as ugly he was a massive outcast in the
entertainment district where beauty was
prized above all other things so even
before his mother died and he became an
orphan it was as if the entire purpose
of utero's life was to give others
someone to mock and belittle he was
forced to eat bugs and insects in order
to survive and everyone was disgusted by
the sight of him but when ume was born
everything changed unlike yutaro ume was
very beautiful and he decided to protect
his little sister from this cruel world
he did everything in his power to keep
her safe fed and warm and thanks to
yutaro's superhuman determination to
protect his sister at all costs the two
of them survived because of all the
bullying that he constantly dealt with
gyutaro became extremely good at
fighting and so he became a debt
collector when someone owed money and
refused to pay yutara would show up and
collect on the debt and he would also
beat down the person whether they paid
the debt or not which led to him
developing a reputation for being
ruthless along with his fighting
abilities he used his appearance that
others found scary as an asset and so he
became a successful debt collector
things were finally looking up for daki
and yutaro but then one night everything
changed that night ume stabbed a samurai
in the eye with a hair comb this samurai
was presumably a client of hers and she
was punished by being nearly burned to
death a grotesque and cruel punishment
but one that the higher castes of the
district had no problem inflicting upon
a member of the lowest caste it's not
clear exactly why ume stabbed the
samurai but i assumed that it was
because he tried to force her to do
things without her consent the demon
slayer wiki claims that she stabbed him
because he insulted yutaro in front of
her but i saw no evidence of that in the
manga so i'm not sure where they're
getting that information from when all
of this happened yutaro was away on a
job and by the time he returned ume was
already burned and practically dead
gyutera was beyond himself with grief
and he vowed that he would do anything
even kill all the gods and buddhas if he
could just have his beautiful little
sister back giutaro was then also
attacked by that same samurai and he was
almost killed after the samurai attacked
him from behind but gyutaro managed to
turn the tables and kill both the
samurai and the madam who ran the
brothel and who got umaine to this
situation in the first place but despite
winning the fight uma and utero were now
both severely injured and it looked like
they were about to die as they were
lying on the street in the snow not a
single human being tried to help them it
was the same as usual they were on their
own and not a single soul even cared if
they lived or died then just as they
were about to die upper moon 2 doma
showed up and offered them the
opportunity to become demons gyutero
knew that his sister was dying and since
he was willing to do anything to save
her he agreed to become a demon and he
never regretted that decision in fact if
he had a hundred other lifetimes he
would have made the same choice humans
never helped him and his sister they
only tormented them relentlessly and
becoming demons is what ultimately saved
them after becoming demons they
eventually rose up through the ranks
until they collectively became upper
moon 6. i don't believe that it was ever
directly explained why exactly ducky and
yutaro were so linked to each other that
they essentially form one collective
body and take up one demon moon rank but
we can assume that this is related to
the precise way in which they became
demons they were both close to death
when doma found them but ducky
especially was nearly gone and she
wasn't even in a position where she
could fully comprehend what was going on
so it is possible that gyutaro agreed to
give up a part of his own body in order
to save daki since he was determined to
save his sister no matter what it takes
maybe this was because daki couldn't
consent at the time so gyutaro had to
make the decision for both of them or
maybe was simply because her body was
too damaged by the fire so gyutaro had
to volunteer his own body either way
they ended up being intrinsically
connected to each other in their demon
forms in fact they are so connected that
the only way to kill them is to behead
both of them at exactly the same time
now i will give another spoiler alert
right now from this point forward i will
discuss the ultimate fate of dakki and
yutaro so if you wanted to just know
their backstory but not what happens to
them in the end you can click off right
now if you're okay with moving forward
then you don't have to do anything
because we will discuss the rest of daki
and yutaro's story eventually after a
long and hard-fought battle that came at
a heavy cost for tengan uzui the demon
slayers managed to use some amazing
teamwork to behead both daki and yutaro
at the same time as their heads lie
dying daki and utero begin to bicker
about which of them is to blame for
their defeat doki calls gytaro ugly and
useless and he calls her a weakling whom
he'd always had to protect but that is
when tanjiro steps in and demonstrates
yet again what a kind-hearted person he
is knowing that these two demons are
already done for he intervenes to stop
them from arguing he reminds them that
all they have is each other no one else
will miss them when they're gone
everyone will just curse them for being
demons who did such horrible things so
now as they lie dying they must stop
this petty bickering they don't really
mean what they're saying so they
shouldn't go off into the afterlife
fighting although they resist this
advice at first tangier's words do
eventually get through to them daki and
yutara regained their memories from back
when they were human and they remembered
the promise that they made to each other
that promise was that they would always
be together and so they head off into
hell together with gyutaro carrying daki
or rather ume on his back like he had
done so many times back when they were
kids looking back now the story of dakin
yutaro was such a cruel and
heartbreaking one they were villains
through and through and in the end they
weren't redeemed they didn't regret
becoming demons they did a lot of evil
deeds and they ended up going to hell
together because of it and yet you can
still sympathize with their truly tragic
story and you could see how they turned
out to be as evil as they did even
though at the end of the day there is no
excuse for their actions they were
treated horribly by other people and
they themselves treated other people
horribly their entire life was one giant
cycle of suffering hatred and revenge
and in the end their story is full of
tragedy including the tragedy that the
two of them themselves endured and also
the tragedy that they willingly brought
upon others after the battle is over
muzan remarks to the other demon moons
that yutara lost because daki had been a
hindrance to him if he had fought by
himself he would have won but because he
kept trying to protect dakian because he
kept trying to make her feel useful he
made too many mistakes and was
ultimately defeated that said this was
the first time that an upper demon moon
was defeated in 113 years and muzon was
definitely not pleased when he learned
that this happened he orders the other
demon moons to work harder to carry out
his orders otherwise they are all
useless to him but this brings me to an
interesting question if muzan really
believed that daki was just a hindrance
to gyutaro and that he would have been
better off without her then why did he
pay a personal visit to daki praise her
and call her a special demon or an
extraordinary demon depending on the
translation at one point he even says to
her that no one is as beautiful and as
strong as her which as we know now is
completely untrue especially that
strength part we never got an exact
answer to this question but part of it
may be due to the fact that ducky was an
oyran as an oiran daki was likely an
important source of income for muzon
even though muzan himself is a lot more
powerful than a human he still lives in
a world that has a lot more humans than
it has demons and in order to remain
hidden from the demon slayers muzan has
to navigate his way through this human
world this means that he needs money and
connections and ducky's status as an
odan definitely provided him with those
important things we know that upper moon
gyoko is well alike by muzan because his
pods fetch a high price so it is clear
that muzan knows the value of money this
could be why he also valued doki or at
least why he wanted her to think that he
values her and that is it the full story
of dakian gyutaro's tragic and dark life
what did you guys think of them as
characters and do you like them as
villains where would you rank them in
terms of your favorite villains in the
demon slayer story i probably like akaza
and doma more and i don't mean i like
doma as a person he's the sickest most
evil maniac out there but that makes him
a good villain and also kokushibo is
just so badass but after those guys doki
and kyutaro are probably my favorites
muzan himself is one of my least
favorite to be honest since his
character doesn't really have nearly as
much depth compared to most of the other
villains
if you guys enjoyed this video and you
want to see more demonstrate content on
the channel just leave a quick like it
only takes a second but it helps a lot
and of course if you're new to the
channel or maybe you watch our videos
but you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet if you could make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications it will really help me out
a lot and of course it's completely free
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror thanks again to
nordvpn for sponsoring this video check
them out link in the description as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys